we deployed in Iraq to rock in 2006 we
then deployed to Kosovo from there we
then deployed to Afghanistan
well you've been through quite a lot so
um yeah hello young man
how are you
[Music]
so then you okay no it's a bad you sell
on the spot I'm their spot isn't it like
which war did you fight him Second World
War
Moira teller was just heard for tiller
and there was 12 of us
and we took part in the North African
campaign and then we went on to the
invasion for two years in them days with
a different war yes yeah to go where you
were sent and some lights went to North
Africa and went right through never got
home till way after d-day the other wars
that followed this it's an entirely
different war than what ours was okay I
think go through generations doesn't it
it goes from one wall to another it's
frightening to see what happens to these
modern wars you're fighting an enemy you
do not know where he is for a stack like
in our war as long as you were going
forward you were going the right way
but you get in Afghanistan and that he
he can come up behind you and you don't
know he's here and from my way of
thinking it I wouldn't like to forth in
that war I'll be honest with you that's
where the to change because I wouldn't
like to fight in your walk because in my
eyes being on a ship it's probably safer
on this ship I can't swim so it you
can't swim
put your sailor and he never taught me
but where would you swim to have you
heard on wait for him all don't matter
whether you could swim or not after
training
I got a battalion and then we deployed
to Belize we went for six weeks in the
jungle and training and that was pre
training for Iraq we deployed in Iraq to
rock in 2006 year 2006 that was a
six-month tour turn into a seven-month
tour and we were deployed to
Saddam's palace and bars yourself and
where we we patrolled the stray cops
after there we come back I went on to do
my promotion
and we then deployed to Kosovo that was
peacekeeping and then from there we then
deployed to Afghanistan
it's a headaches had so completely
different operations altogether from
armored force well you've been through
quite a lot on them yeah
what are your feelings towards the enemy
now in comparison to at the time that's
a good man at the time I didn't it's
it's weird because I'm gonna probably
stand out there is I didn't have any
hate for them I believe that we were
fighting in someone else's country and
they were defending it in a way but I
think that's one of the reasons why I
left because I am I didn't believe in it
in the end I think I think I thought
that hard and I was fighting an enemy so
much that I was I was equal to them if
so I'm gonna fight if someone can get
the number of men in front of me and
fight me and my men to the extreme that
they were fighting us then hats off to
them myself
well we fought the Germans to win the
war that's what was bred into you and it
took me until about 1970 before I could
really you know see me way clear I have
nothing against him now it took me all
that time to realize they were the same
as those doing what they had to do have
you ever fired a weapon yes on the
landing craft I was an anti-aircraft
corner we had six Orlick ins and a
12-pounder on her so where I fired that
many times suitable it's a different
thing it's not like firing a rifle no
it's like a soldier has to rely on a
rifle doesn't he oh yeah I rely on me
antiaircraft gun whenever you're in
imminent danger you're called to action
stations and if they planes come out
here then you have to fight back
and on the orluk and you had a shield
which you you look through the gap so to
speak it always gave me that feeling
that he couldn't it yeah but which was
silly we're thinking but it gave me a
better feeling of comfort if you know
what I mean see we've also just rifles
we're just well rifles and and we had
their GP mgs which was seven sixty
Belfast which that most of them would
you be lost without your right audio
gone one yeah on their Afghan either
sections while a section of a large some
very very good lads as well we would get
in three sixty ambushes so would be
basically we'd get hit by an ie D so
you'd have someone from the front right
left they're coming from the top of the
compounds and they basically just
spraying it with rapid fire with seven
six two once you got into the firefight
you can never tell what was going to
happen but you always knew it's gonna be
like a well-oiled machine the way your
SOPs kick into place the way you know
your lads would did is new because the
march on your des beans you knew exactly
what we're doing how do you think
soldiers are viewed in society it all
depends are the media portrays us
remember going back when we come back
from Iraq we landed in seaside and we
had groups of people that weren't happy
that we were there and that and they
were British people because the media
portrayed us as killers as murderers
flipping the coin when we come back from
Afghan we were portrayed as heroes so
the whole country rejoiced to go I'll
save our heroes obviously your
generation you were well I think the war
did lasted so long with our that they
were glad to see the people back home
and I think most soldiers and sailors
any serviceman
just looked upon they they say thank you
to them forgetting their freedom in one
way they were glad to see the war over I
can understand the difference now
different generation
yeah there's different war well you find
it they know when you're in a war zone
and as you know you've got that constant
stress above your ads of what's next
what's next in your console on high
alert a year constantly high rate irate
it takes one person to look at you and
you ready to fight straight away
hence why we're meeting called when we
when soldiers come back home so on
Locksley the wrong way you're already in
fight mode it's been twelve years I'm
still in fight mode Nam I don't think
I'll ever change I all ever change that
if you fight in a war it's him or us so
to speak and that's my way of thinking
and so let it be when I was out there it
was my lunch
my legs are coming home no matter what I
don't care my logical my own very left
lost a member of your company it's a
wonder one syllable of those at the same
time because we've lost quite a lot from
our grip from a battalion of our
regiment I'll say I say I say regiment
because is one RG j & c RG j today's
attend the 10th anniversary for a lot we
lost call their poor McAleese he was my
square we you know we we love we lost
him 10 years today we lost we've lost
quite a lot yeah I've been golly I think
I'll leave it there like don't to go to
too much into it like have you ever
suffered a serious injury I've only had
a backlash from the gun which sometimes
written or again half and it gets hot
thing sort of blows and you get a flash
it's a nothing case
serious yeah part of my a few broken
like sprains and broken wrists and stuff
like that and major one would be
probably mental mentally I know this is
this is you know it's a massive epidemic
that's going through the military at the
moment for veterans I'm just all servant
is mental health past 13 years I've
really suffered they really really
suffered but I've sort of like butter
that backwards buttered it backwards and
kept moving forward I mean it was
get moving forward and I think with me
age now again I've got the age where
it's like well I've got my family and
all that I've got to stay straight
you're mean but it does creeps back a
lot it does treat my car I figure out
for me daughter is kicking up the ask
why I was like you mean but I think if
the dead somebody still be like that you
mean it's but I know a lot of odd Salah
girls love a lot a lot of soldiers are
suffering do you miss the forces well
that's a good question now I don't think
I missed it I was away about four and a
half years I served and I was glad to
get out and no that's my answer to that
I don't about yourself no a lot of lots
dare issue of it and you say oh yeah I
missed the army or we should go back I
think what is is is regiments that's the
regimented you know such a routine where
that is your life and you do that for
three to seven to twenty two years I
left and it was like I'm sure earlier
but it's because it was you're known
it's I don't miss it I miss the lads of
comradery yeah I miss that's about the
only thing you miss yeah yeah
although me wrong I miss firefights
believe it or not I miss get into
firefights I miss a weapon handling I
miss teaching it but I can be replaced
by anything I mean if you find them
another passion or another loving life
you would place like with like your main
is there anything you regret about your
service really yeah through that well
through the years I am proud to have
been a part of it it took all my youth
if I hadn't have been there I'd have
missed quite a lot and no I don't regret
it one hate it I don't think I regret it
because it's like what I said what it's
what I've gained from it I mean mentally
it's been mentally draining once I've
got out but at the same time it's
strengthening at the same time so where
something suffering someone else is
strengthening you mean so I'm becoming
better
what you want to tell your story from my
point of view it may be there help the
younger generation they don't know about
your war I don't know about my war and
they comment on this sort of thing
people watch it and they realize it's
part of history I would think so I hope
so
all of me it's like for 10 years after
get out I say software that I went to
the dark place and I kept it to myself
and when every time someone mentioned
the military or my dad switch off and
walk away they want to know I'm still a
little bit like that now but since I've
thought since this year I've started a
new project I've been talking about my
career and my story my mental health for
my by fight and struggle and all that
carry on it's it's actually helping me
it's helped me talking about it more
importantly to Kabu someone starting a
dark room right now wasn't left the
house at sea weeks and their scroll on
the phone and they come up they come
across a large Bible they watch didn't
listen to this listen to me and you and
they go I've been for that I've seen
this or that's worse than me lost not as
worse than me and if he stand up and
they walk out the front door and they
give it a go then we saved one and it's
worth it so that that's why I talk about
my story and I want but I wouldn't have
known your story if I hadn't have
listened to it here would I
I've learnt a lot from you and I hope
our little talk today has helped in that
way well not just the younger generation
I think the oldest as well as me
like if anyone makes me thanks to me yes
[Music]
you